I have to admit that this story kind of bums
me out and you'll understand why in a little
bit, it relates it relates to my youth in
some sense.
Fox Business host Maria Bartiromo is now sinking
so low that that it's actually depressing
you.
I am sure at this point have heard that Joe
Biden won the presidential election, that
the Electoral College confirmed it.
Joe Biden has most of his cabinet selected.
Donald Trump lost in court like 50 times or
something like that.
The Supreme Court has said no thanks to his
case.
And Fox Business host Maria Bartiromo.
Now, really a second rate Fox host, even by
their standards, is a really aggressive Trump
brownnoser and claimed yesterday that an intel
source wait for it.
An Intel source told her Donald Trump actually
won the election.
Let's look at the clip and then I'm going
to tell you about the sort of tragic downfall
of Maria Bartiromo, an intel source telling
me that President Trump did, in fact, win
the election.
He says that it is up to the Supreme Court
to hear suits from other cases across the
country to stop the clock.
This follows the high court's refusal to hear
the lawsuit from Texas Attorney General Ken
Paxton.
Challenging results in four swing states.
Now, you might say, well, David, if an intel
source did tell her that she's not lying,
she's merely reporting it and the intel source
could simply be wrong or mistaken.
But is that really the argument you want to
make?
That's the hill you want to die on.
Maria Bartiromo is more than 50 years old
and she's been a journalist in some way, shape
or form for almost 30 years.
And we're standing behind what she said is
OK and responsible to air as long as some
Intel person really did tell her with no vetting
or connection or actual evidence.
She says this is what they told me.
It's actually shocking how Maria Bartiromo
has fallen from being a great financial reporter
to being what is, in short, a conspiracy theorist.
Trump suck up.
That's what she is at this point.
And the way this relates to my youth is when
I first got into trading stocks back in the
year 2000, when I was in high school, I started
watching CNBC because I guess that's what
you do, or at least what you did at the time.
And at the time, Maria Bartiromo really did
excellent interviews of big time Fortune 500
CEOs.
She would hold them accountable for her interview.
Preparation was second to none.
She was fantastic.
And she was the first TV journalist to report
live from the floor of the New York Stock
Exchange.
She won Emmys for that.
She was well recognized by the Italian American
community in New York City related to her
amazing story, working her way up from her
early days in Brooklyn as a kid, being a coat
checker at her dad's restaurant.
I mean, it's just an amazing story.
And she was a top notch interviewer for more
than a decade.
And then she joined Fox in 2013.
Things sort of started to get a little bit
shaky.
But then when Trump ran in 2016, she developed
like an on air relationship with Trump and
got to interview Donald Trump and became essentially
a dishonest PR person for Donald Trump rather
than a journalist, which sadly sometimes happens
to people when they go over to Fox News.
And it really is sad.
So here's my my ask of you.
Don't let this happen to me.
Hold me accountable.
I don't think it would happen.
But I'm telling you right now, if I do something
like this, you can go ahead and cancel your
membership.
It would be embarrassing and pathetic to me,
to my family, to the people that have supported
this show.
But I'm sure it's lucrative for her.
And who doesn't want to have a friend in the
White House?
Right.
That is that that's actually one of the things
that sometimes I think those who are only
very casual observers of media don't get,
which is that that the appeal of access to
people in power makes media people do really
crazy things sometimes.
And I've said before how I don't really care
about being friends with politicians.
There are a number of elected officials in
the U.S. House and in other offices that that
I'm in touch with.
And we have what I guess we would call personal
relationships.
But they're not like, you know, if they do
something wrong and it's even happened, I
cover it.
And I'm not really impressed.
I've said we shouldn't DFI these people, but
maybe when it gets to a certain level and
it's the president, maybe if the president
wants to be your friend, you just repeat whatever
nonsense the president wants you to say.
I don't know.
But it's really a tragedy.
What's happened to Maria Bartiromo.